[Music]
hi everyone thanks for being here
I'm palak I'm a product managers on
google kubernetes engine and I have with
me Ken hi I'm Ken Owens I'm a software
engineer on Google kubernetes engine I
work on the workloads team and in open
source I contribute primarily to the
workloads API that's in the special
interest group applications I'm a
co-chair of that group so today we'll
talk about how to build portable data
processing workloads on google
kubernetes engine the amount of data
that companies are dealing with is
exploding information is a valuable
commodity there is an increasing need to
generate relevant and intelligent
insights from that data to make business
critical decisions but doing so is not
easy especially when you are dealing
with the amongest amount of data and
tools and technologies that are changing
at a rapid pace users need a way to
incorporate intelligent decision-making
in their applications while iterating
quickly on their applications they also
want to use the latest machine learning
and data processing technologies in a
way which is easy to understand and
doesn't have a very steep learning curve
developers need to offload the
operational burden of actually deploying
and managing an application in
production clusters while at the same
time they are asking for high
performance and acceleration to get
intelligent insights at an at a
lightning pace enter containers and
kubernetes containers are sealed
deployment units that provide efficient
isolation the usability and portability
through containers you can modernize
your infrastructure and launch and
iterate on features much faster
kubernetes has emerged as the leading
container orchestration platform it does
all the heavy lifting for you for
managing operating upgrading and scaling
your production clusters moreover it is
open source so you can move your
applications and workloads to any cloud
without any vendor lock-in today we will
talk about how kubernetes provides the
best platform for learning those data
processing applications we will show
you demo and a technical deep dive on
both spark and airflow applications on
kubernetes over to you can so today I
want to talk a little bit about the
pieces that you use to build the data
processing application on top of
kubernetes
how many you guys are familiar with pods
most of you so most of you have used
kubernetes or have some experience with
it
okay so this might be a bit of an
overview for you so kubernetes is all
about resources like when you create a
pod a volume whatever it's mirrored by
some real object or some object in
storage inside of the system at the base
you've got a pod this is your atom of
scheduling resource allocation it's
basically a loosely or tightly coupled
set of containers well with the shared
name space share networking and volumes
and they have a shared life cycle they
live together they die together usually
you only one run container per pod
unless you've got sidecars but you know
sometimes you run more than one so
volumes PVS and PVCs these are the atoms
of durable storage right so a volume is
basically something that appears inside
of your pod on the filesystem you can
use to access your data if it's not
backed by a pv then it's ephemeral it
disappears in the pod dies if it is
backed by a pv on google cloud that's
backed by a persistent disk when the pod
dies your data is still in the disk
PVCs are the way you associate those TVs
it's the way you provision those PBS
it's the way you get your volumes into
your pot and get your data off that's
interesting but you also need to get
data across the network into a pod to
use that to do that use services and
this is basically the atom of networking
it programs network to route traffic to
pods and it made provision load
balancers if you expose it externally so
pods get lis it's the basic workload you
can run just one single pod right but
it's not very interesting in comes the
workloads API so deployments and replica
sets these are for your 12 factor apps
might not be interesting for data
processing in specific like your
coordinator processing workloads but you
still need 12 factor acts in order to
access those workloads in order to have
administrative consoles and all a
deployment is is basically I'm going to
replicate this pod
in an identical way n times and when I
updated I updated in a consistent manner
but I can do it concurrently so if I
have three pods I can update two at a
time not particularly good for databases
not particularly good for staple
applications in general that that is why
we created staple said so staples that
creates M pods in the same way a
deployment does but these pods are
different in that they have durable
provision storage and they also have a
durable network identity and what that
means is if you kill the pod and you
bring it back it gets the same storage
it gets a same C name it gets the same
SRV records the rollouts are slightly
different - they're not concurrent
they're ordered in sequential meaning
that if I have three pods I wait to a
pod one is running and ready before I
launch pod - pod two dies I don't kill
pod one until pod two is completely
terminated and then daemon sets create
one pod for every new in the cluster
from the perspective of data processing
if you're running something like HDFS or
any other distributed file system your
data nodes you want to put them on
particular set of nodes in the cluster
you don't want any of them when a new
node comes up you want a new data node
daemon sets are allow you to do that so
those are all interesting from the
perspective of workloads that run
continuously the pods of a stateful set
they never well what they do terminate
they get restarted it's same for
deployment same for a daemon said but
with Batchelor workloads you have a
difference right they run to completion
if I start a spark job I want the job to
eventually stop running when it's
completed maybe I wanted to restart if
it failed that's where job comes in
creates pods that run to completion
Council number of successes and once a
specified number of successes have
occurred the job terminates and it says
it's completed successfully and cron
jobs are just a way to manage time-based
jobs you can do one offs you can do
repeating ones that run at a specific
interval so the one thing we realized we
were building the kubernetes api is that
we're not good at we can build you
primitives but we can't build every
primitive you're ever going to need so
none of the resources are actually
special you can bring your own resources
these are custom resource definitions
and it basically allows you just to
define your own resource of thing
if you define job as the resource that
we use for the batchview one job you can
create a spark job you can create an
airflow cluster and these become part of
the API in the same way and
fundamentally the same way as any other
resource to act on a mill you need to
bring a custom controller so all the
resources that we've talked about so far
each have a custom controller that ships
with kubernetes but you can easily
install your own controller to act on
the resources you define so we've talked
a lot about the pieces of these data
processing pipelines the question is how
do I get those onto my cluster so one
way to do this is using manifests and a
manifest is basically just a yamo file
that contains most of those atoms that
we talked about before you deploy it you
apply it it runs and it creates the
workload for you the problem with this
is if you're trying to get something off
of the shelf like go get a yamo file
that somebody else has created and
deploy it in your cluster what if your
monitoring solution isn't the same as
the one that was found online or what if
your lifecycle management solution is
totally different the manifest
isn't really portable from that
perspective so in comes hell now helm is
a kubernetes package manager and what it
allows you to do is to template those
manifests and apply a set of values to
them so it still doesn't solve for
lifecycle management but let's say you
have a template for the logging solution
you can just plug that in via values yam
or if you want to change configuration
of values that memo will allow you to
change that but really for complicated
orchestration which is typically the use
case we see for data processing it's
still not sufficient so if you combine a
custom controller with a custom resource
you get what's colloquially called the
operator pattern so the operator pattern
is basically I'm going to teach my
cluster to understand what a spark job
is but I'm going to write a controller
to act on that spark job and I'm going
to encode the day 1 and day 2 operations
necessary for keeping that cluster up
inside of that controller inside of that
operator and that seems to be the
dominant way that we were
the problem my colleagues are going to
give you some demos later on
contributions that we've made to the
community in particular for this so just
diving a bit deeper than two operators
for users to really trust kubernetes to
run reduction workloads like databases
it needs to be super the easy to
automate it and the way to scale it is
to actually automate how you manage it
an application operators of an operator
is basically like a robot which performs
some of those functions of an apps ops
group think of a DBA how critical a DBA
is to the enterprise so this is really
useful for stateful applications they
encapsulate the operational concerns of
running an application on kubernetes and
they run these application in a
declarative fashion which kubernetes
understands the control loop observes
the existing state it looks at what the
desired state is it sees what the
difference is needed and then acts upon
the system to actually reach that
desired state now I'll talk about how
Google kubernetes
engine is providing some of the best
tools and technologies to run those data
processing workloads we recently
launched a marketplace called GCP
marketplace and recently launched the
kubernetes section within it so what
that means is now the GCP marketplace
has native integration into gke you can
click to deploy stateful applications on
GK view those applications on the UI as
well as on your console we made
available first party Google develop
solutions like spark and airflow to
start with as well as several
third-party solutions by vendors besides
rad we have also been leading the open
source efforts to develop something
called an aptly source previously there
was no concept of an application in
kubernetes there was a bunch of workload
controllers like deployments at stateful
sets and others but we didn't define an
application with this app resource you
can now view and manage your application
effectively on kubernetes you can also
leverage some of the cutting-edge data
services that GCP provides for instance
bigquery cloud a I start driver TP use
an GP
you can natively integrate those on your
kubernetes applications on google
kubernetes engine so the first operator
that we launched was the spark operator
we had seen some users that many of them
want to run data processing in batch
analytics workloads on kubernetes in a
way which is native to kubernetes they
wanted to use QB cuttle when running
their spark jobs the spark operator is
available on github as well as on the
GCP marketplace and I would like to
invite Jana and Leigh who leads the
SPARC operator to give a demo and talk
more about the operator
so before I start just want to go since
like in how many of you run spark on
cornelisz as already okay out of you
okay hopefully the number will get
bigger you know after the talk so lot of
sharps Mark Harper days basically
project that Falls you know the recent
operator pattern like you know so at its
core there's the you know some customer
resource types and also the
corresponding custom controllers that
you know extent the kubernetes api and
control plant weeds application domain
knowledge in this case will be a spark
so what is there's actually two types of
you know customer resources one is
called spark application which is you
know like one-time spark jobs and those
there's also a scheduled spark
application type which is for you know
time-based are applications so you can
actually run like you know across
schedule on for for your spark
applications so there's a spark operator
is basically like you know a is a custom
controller that watches these customer
resources and you know once it sees them
there if there's any new resources
coming or there's any updates - you know
existing resources will actually take
actions so in a case of like you know
spark so it will actually run sparks are
made for you so you don't need to run
that manually and you know once that
once an application gets submitted it'll
actually monitors the departs for the
applications for you and you know
aggregate status into the status section
of your customer resource object so you
can naturally get you know status of
your application in one place instead of
a unit like actually going through all
the parts individually so let me
actually switch to the demo machine now
okay so yeah this is where the project
is hosted well you know feel free to
take a look and tried it out so before I
start the first thing I'm gonna show you
actually it's a how an application looks
like so this is a spark application
customer resource so you can actually
see it allows you to specify pretty much
every pieces of thing for
in your spark application needs like you
know what what is men cost you want to
use what is the men application for we
want to use in this case the application
jar is actually hosted on GCSE and
runtime will be downloaded by the driver
before you know it was it's gets
launched and you can also specify you
know the application arguments and what
kind of image we want to use and also
like you know spark or Hadoop
configuration you want to use for your
application and then it has a section
for you to specify all your dependencies
you can actually use you know remote
remote dependency on HDTV servers or GCS
or on your you know I'm from HDFS
clusters and there's also separate
sections for you to specify how the
driver and executor should look like so
yeah with that so in this particular
case actually the application I'm gonna
demo is a one that try to find out you
know on github
what are the goal on get up project that
needs help from you know contributors
the most so this particular application
Walker reads public github dataset on on
bigquery and then writes a result back
to bigquery and intermediate result
being written to GCS so this is actually
you know it's not you're interacting
with suppose bigquery and GCS at the
same time okay so the first thing I'm
gonna do is actually create this
customer resource object for this you
can offer either use Kuby control or the
smart operator actor also shipped with
command light to call smart control
which you know makes dealing with these
customer resources even easier
so what I was like this wall actually
creates this customer resource to the
API server so once that's done that well
what the custom controller will actually
sees this new you know a customer
resource object and it will actually run
sparks MA for you and that will creates
the driver pot so after that I'm gonna
demo like you know how we can actually
grab locks up from the driver so you can
see this is actually you know grabbing
the driver logs you can also do
streaming like this will basically like
you know better and you know when more
locks hum sings it will show you you can
also actually not only you know grab the
driver lock all those also locks of
innovative executor pods so to do that
you just use the - key option then you
basically tells like you know what is
the actually door ID you're interested
in like in this case if I say one so
there's actually you know fetched the
locks of executors one so that's four
four locks
so this mela - also comes with the
status sub command for you to actually
act like no so what is the current
status of the app will show you like
another driver pot name like where the
driver is running and also you know
those individual states of you know each
individual executor pods so you can also
use could be control describe to do the
same thing like you know will give you
also the entire spec of your custom
object as well as so ok so the next
thing I'm gonna show is actually to see
how we can access the spark driver UI so
the UI is running inside a driver so for
to do it out I'm gonna do a port
forwarding from a local machine to you
know the driver pod so if you actually
is Kubik control you have to basically
know like you know was that what is the
name of the driver part but if you use
for control you don't need to do that
because actually so we know like you
know so we're the drive
is running so so we cannot do that
automatically okay so this is actually
you know forwarding from four zero four
zero two four zero four zero on the
driver path now if we go to so you see
that you know the driver UI and it gives
you information about individual
executors as well so in this case the
actual stages haven't started but this
is you know so you get a sense like how
you can access their driver UI using
port forwarding so this is actually
pretty straightforward so the apps is
that you're running on a GPU cluster
here so if I do a refresh you can see
you know one driver Paz got launched
then it in terms like you know it's
actually created three executors pots so
often running so let's stop this and to
actually if you you know once your app
is done you want to get it get rid off
you know these parts what you can do an
extractor just to do this then will
delete your spark application customer
object and in turn you know your your
all your paws will be gone after this so
yeah this is pretty much you know what I
want to demo today but you can
definitely check out you know the
documentation on our github site about
you know other features that we provide
like you know so you can actually also
run chrome based applications and also
you can even actually use the spark ctrl
command line to to automatically shape
your locker dependency to GCS so you
don't have to do that manually so what
happens like know if you have local
dependencies in your spec application
specification so a smart controller see
them and upload them to a bucket you
specify then we'll actually you know do
a substitution from these local
dependencies to the corresponding one
sound on TCS then some if you know the
verted spark applications back to the
API server so you don't need to do every
these kind of seemed manually every
scene is handled for you so yeah so you
know traffic go ahead and check out our
github site and about documentation you
know those kind of things yeah so Wells
I've got a slack channel you know feel
free to join and post questions or
comments yeah thanks
well next I'm gonna hand over to my
colleague Barney who works on air flow
and he does a search those countries in
some communities so who we giving a demo
on air flow operator on birdie nice
thanks you wanna see all right hi my
name is Barney I work in Google as part
of the kubernetes team I'm here to
present about the air flow operator
before I tell what an OP what the after
operator does let's take a look at what
and our flow is also is a platform for
deploying managing scheduling and
monitoring workflows workflow is dag
directed acyclic graph written in Python
so a flow has a typical installation of
our flow has many components like the UI
scheduler workers and the broker and the
sequel node so deploying air flow is a
complex and they were with many moving
parts and different configurations for
each of the components the way you could
the way it's typically deployed right
now is using health shots but like Ken
mentioned that is that does not take
care of the lifecycle management of a
natural deployment and also the
developer experience with an air flow is
lacking because you need to copy the DAX
that you're developing into the cluster
before you can test it out and and if
you expect individual you know
developers to stand up their own
clusters it's not an easy thing for them
to do and this word the airflow operator
comes in
the airflow operator is a custom
resource is a bunch of custom resources
with a custom controller what it does is
it makes it dead easy and simple to
deploy airflow on kubernetes so the
operator I just mentioned it has custom
resources there are a custom resource is
a declarative spec that tells you what
the what to do or not how to do it and
there are two custom resources that the
airflow operator works on the base and
the cluster let's switch to the demo and
I can show you how the resources look
alright there you go
I hope you guys can see it all increase
all right there you go this is the base
resource you can see the base resource
has two components of my sequel and NSS
storage the cluster resource has the
rest of our flow components like the UI
scheduler work worker nodes and the
broker so if you notice the CRD expect
for the base is very minimal you don't
have to specify the images or how do you
bring up my sequel how do you how do you
set up the you know the database inside
it so user name the root password all of
it is taken care by the airflow operator
alright but you could customize the see
a custom resource by specifying your own
resource requirements or placement
properties the good thing is it just
uses cubes ETL to create and manage
these custom resources so let's deploy
this and before that let me start the
operator
so I'm creating the custom resource and
you can notice on the logs on the left
that the operator would start picking up
you know I'm picking up the this custom
resource and deploying the stateful sets
and other resources that are needed for
standing it up you see that it created
the my sequel Stetson said ask lesson
and a festival set and you also see it
created a secret or dynamically for
setting up the root password for my
sequel and the parts already at this
point
let's look at the other cost you know
customer resource so this is a cluster
customer resource it has we can pick the
executors of choice for airflow but what
I'm using is a salary executor which is
a multi node deployment of airflow and
we use radius as the broker and all we
need to say is which version of the
image or image that you want to use and
you also notice that there's the dag
section where you specify where that
DAGs need to be pulled from and this
makes it dead simple for someone using
air flow to specify all the their
environment in the same file and let the
operator do its do the deployment for
them
I'm creating the cluster CRE and you'll
notice that the operator is deploying
the parts and the stateful side and you
notice that two new secrets have been
created one for Redis and one for the
scheduler so what your operator does is
it creates a database dynamically in my
sequel for this instance of T of you
know our flow cluster so you have the UI
you have reduce your scheduler and two
worker nodes that are up and running
give it a couple of seconds and try to
access this to see if it's up typically
we do port forwarding to access it
because it's easier that way
so you're a hopeless Trezza we can run a
quick just to make sure that it's
working run a dag
yeah so these are the tasks it's running
once it's completed I'll show you how
the dad looks like it's almost time
yeah there you go so listen so it shows
that it ran the dag three times one is
yeah what just was triggered in by me
and if you open the rector's how the the
steps within the dag look like so we
have we are deployed a working airflow
cluster within a couple of minutes and
we were able to test it let's take a
look at the configuration here you
notice that it's said to be the executor
is celery executors and if you look at
the connection string for my sequel you
notice that it auto-generate say
username password as well as the
database that needs to be used for this
our flow instance and it connects to the
MC base as sequel that we deployed
earlier as part of the base yardie so
unserious my sequel alright so i just
demoed how easy it is to deploy a multi
node airflow cluster using to see our
days let's go ahead and deploy one more
cluster
all right this time I'm going to deploy
celery with the GCS after dark source
maybe I'll show how it looks like before
deploying
all right you notice it's almost similar
to the earlier cluster configuration
except that you point to the GCS bucket
as dark source
yeah
all right it's deployed the second
airflow cluster if you notice I didn't
deploy the base for the second cluster
it reuses the base from the first
cluster you could do it this way to
improve resource usage and this is
particularly useful if you want
development disposable development
clusters that you want to hand it over
to the developers
let's try connecting to the new cluster
No
and this is a second clusters we just
deployed and notice that it doesn't have
the state here because it's pretty it's
brand-new if you look at the
configuration for my sequel let's go
back here if you notice it has different
connection string because these were
dynamically generated for the second
cluster and this is oh we are able to
share the same base across components
I'm sorry clusters alright let's let me
go ahead and deploy one more cluster and
this is something new okay
all right there is something different
about this cluster if you notice it
doesn't deploy the worker nodes it just
deploys a UI and the scheduler the
reason is this cluster uses the
kubernetes executors which does not need
worker nodes to be pre deployed sorry
right here go the executor is given it
is here so what happens is when you run
i'm it connect to the new one and
all right so let's look at the
configuration for the new cluster
all right so if you notice it's using
the kubernetes executors at this point
and of course the my sickle string is
going to be different from the other two
clusters and all right
really I just fired you notice that it's
generating pods on the fly so only all
the tasks in your dag will end up as
spots it's similar to the spark operator
the good part about this is you don't
need to have dedicated worker pods
running all the time and and there are
some use cases where it's useful so
that's the kubernetes executor so if we
notice the operator makes it be easy to
deploy air flow with different
configurations one would look celery
executor of one with kubernetes
executors and a developer could also use
the local or a sequential executor as
well and you're able to do all this with
just two custom resources ok as against
these many stateful search secrets and
all these things so and it's not just
the deployment that the airflow cluster
takes care of it also takes care of
managing sorry data operations like if
you want to scale out
all right all right if you want to scale
out and exist horizontally scale a
cluster that you already deployed you
can edit the custom resource and change
the replicas so I'm going to bump it up
to four
all right you see that it's creating the
new workers for the first cluster that
we deploy so what it does underlying is
it goes and bumps up the replicas for
the stateful set which in turn creates
new parts for you and you could also
change the executor type of your cluster
once it's deployed so for example if you
deployed a celery executor and switch it
to carbonite as it deletes the worker
nodes for you so it gives you the
dynamic ability and it's it's not just
scaling and deployment it also makes
sure your clusters are resilient what I
mean by that as kubernetes does a good
job of handling pod failures and node
failures but if someone accidentally
deletes your stateful set the executor
monitors that and it recreates it for
you it just makes it a little bit more
risky and then just using kubernetes
manifests and for us I think that's
about it thank you guys so if there are
three things that you want to take away
from this session there are as follows
number one kubernetes is no longer the
platform for just running stateless
services you can now with on complex
stateful applications on kubernetes and
manage them in a very easy way you just
saw two amazing demos on spark and
airflow which could be run and managed
in just a couple of minutes secondly
with the use of operators you can do we
can perform de n kind of operations
not just on Google Cloud but on any
cloud you can run those operators on
your private data centers and have the
portability and the consistent
experience that you want across your
clouds for the cut further for the
business critical multi cloud strategy
you can discover these applications on
the GCP marketplace to begin with
including the SPARC and air flow
operators and third Google Cloud to the
right some of the best tools to run
these applications on gke if you want to
run an open source service you can use
spark and air flow but if you want
manage so
with SLS as well as production great
support you can use data proc as well as
cloud composer for these managed
instances you can integrate with some of
the other GCP services like bigquery
cloud storage stag driver GPUs Antep use
into your kubernetes clusters and click
to deploy these applications on GK not
just from Google but also from
third-party partners that we are working
very closely with thank you for your
time and we welcome any questions
[Music]